fora tv' idea immersion
[Music]
I started my my career as a photographer
back in the Netherlands where I grew up
and I began to photograph in a city park
in Rotterdam where I was a student at
the time I'm doing moody pictures of the
four seasons and writing haikus to go
with him and that was in the early 1970s
and then I didn't really get into you
have wildlife photography until after
I'd moved to California and that was in
the late 70s I'd completed an education
in environmental economics it was very
interested in ecosystem services was a
very novel concept at the time and came
to UCSC to study environmental impact
planning but you know West Coast has a
lot to offer as we all know and I really
became more interested in a photographic
career down in pursuing a ir's and EIS
which are just big reports with lots of
data in them so here's an early image
when I was pursuing elephant seals at
onion wave oh and it led to interesting
images and then the world got bigger and
bigger and I started doing assignment
work for the geographic this is a on
location shot from field work I did in
New York of anga Delta in Botswana and
the the encounters got a little bit more
intense hip I'm not happy with my
presence and yet I my thinking am I in
my photography has undergone a steady
change in development since those early
days yeah at first I was interested in
wildlife photographing animals one at a
time and then gradually I realized that
you know through the power of media and
applications of photography that I could
reach out to a heck of a lot of people
and I began to look at animals as
ambassadors for ecosystems and here's
two images that give a wider perspective
previous one was a wandering albatross
on South Georgia island
this is an image from a project I did on
Madagascar where all these lemurs live
and so my thinking grew along with the
perspectives of scientists and and
conservationists and ecosystems were
were replaced as a concept to look at
nature of it with the term biodiversity
in the mid 1990s and there's two three
people who thought of that term almost
simultaneously was Ed Wilson and Tom
Lovejoy and somebody else and
biodiversity has been our reigning
paradigm for referring to the
complexities of life on Earth it's
really more looking at nature as a web
of relations rather than counting
species by themselves and the geographic
asked me in the late 90s if I wanted to
illustrate concepts of biodiversity for
a theme issue that the magazine monitor
published just before we would leave the
20th century and go into the 21st
century so that really forced me to
think much more conceptually about
nature than I done before and here's a
couple of images that I made for that
assignment a cloud forest in Peru where
really there's no subject that stands
out it's really about how all these
living organisms coexist in the same
place the assignment is also about the
you know the the ongoing process of
exploration and discovery
this fellow studies cated it's tropical
grasshoppers and he's literally in the
act of touching a new species that had
not been described yet and he knew
because he knows them all
I do a lot of research for these for
these assignments and independent
project and I'd learned that these
horseshoe crabs have an amazing life
history they around for hundreds of
millions of years this is a photo I made
in a museum in of a fossilized horseshoe
crab 150 million years old and it looks
exactly like modern crabs and I had that
knowledge in the back of my head one
evening when I was there at the tide
line this is one of these spring tide
evenings and thousands of crabs came out
of the water and the light faded all
references to modern New Jersey
disappeared and I realized I wasn't
looking at the present anymore
I was looking at the Silurian I was
looking at an era of and the very first
animal just making their way out of the
water and that's how long these crabs
have been around and after I made this
image I thought that's an interesting
idea
looking at the present but seeing the
past and and that's when the idea for
this project was born I thought well if
I could visualize the past in New Jersey
what might I be able to do if I start
researching other locations and and that
became the start for this journey
through time
this image really symbolizes you know
the the the the beginnings of life all
the key ingredients are out there
there's there's energy from the Sun
there's warm water there's a substrate
and there's a very interesting mix of
minerals and other ingredients
so the story of life is of course is
made up of you know big leaps your
innovations and then there are periods
of consolidation and big thinkers like
Stephen Jay Gould and Niles Eldredge
kind of summed it all up in the theory
of punctuated equilibrium but you know
that's their terminology I think more
simplistically in terms of innovation
you know where the big breaks well when
life came out of the water that was a
big break and that's symbolized by this
image the tracks of a giant sea reptile
big dudes leatherbacks
biggest of all living sea turtles the
most ancient ones as well and they
really look like sea monsters when you
sit there on the beach and Surinam and
this thing comes out of the water it
really is like an apparition
through land plants arose leafless at
first this is another big break of
course in water plants can you know use
use water they're buoyant on land they
have to fight against gravity and the
vascular system was a was a real
breakthrough and once plants learn how
to do that once they learn how to stay
upright they grow in size and shape and
the first trees came along and you know
according to geologists among the first
trees were giant club mosses which are
still around in the understory in
forests that just a couple of inches
long and and they just lie flat on along
the ground these days so I wanna show a
mystery so I had to find some big
specimens and made this one look as if
it's a real tree the fundamental forms
of ferns followed barring spores that
foreshadow seeds and together ferns and
lichens began to cover the earth
Oh land life turn stuff Joss form first
teeth come later this is a giant
tortoise in a Galapagos Island
slumbering in a in a pool and in that
transition from amphibians to reptiles
of course we have another innovation
with eggs with eggs life had a chance on
land to shelter new life in the making
that's how it broke away from water and
this is old textbook biology of course
but I'd forgotten all this stuff and I
plunged into it and to me it was just
like a revelation after revelation oh
that's how it happened and then of
course I had to look for images that
simplified his complex phenomenon
umberto life gains new mobility
flamingos cover continents migrations
get on the way flamingos we now know
through DNA analysis were among the very
earliest families of birds that evolved
and I haven't really changed that much
their habitats been unchanged the first
birds witnessed the emergence of
flowering plants it's a pure coincidence
birds the very first birds have been
pinpointed to 150 million years ago the
very first flowering plants are dated to
140 million years ago so complete
coincidence but yet there's something
nice about that because nature gets very
lyrical in birds and in flowering plants
so we linked them in in the book and you
know sometimes birds and flowers can
even be made to look like one another
this is of water lily
sixty-five million years ago the earth
was fairly complete there were reptiles
big reptiles on land in the water and in
the air
there were ecosystems of all kinds in
them something big hit the earth and of
course we all know what that was I was
at asteroid that hit planet Earth and a
world vanished in flames and you know
this was only discovered 2025 years ago
by two scientists from UC Berkeley who
at first were ridiculed are now can't be
and most big discoveries take a while
before they sink into the world of
science but it was not a pleasant time
to be here was very smoky for a couple
of years when the skies cleared a new
world was born a world fit for mammals
mammals had been around but you know not
really been able to diversify much
because they were out competed by by
reptiles or so the conventional wisdom
goes but then the evolutionary slate is
wiped clean mammals had their chance and
they owe their success to this
innovation jaws the teeth teeth that
adapt very easily to different habitats
different needs and you know these are
the jaws to belong to a giant Hedgehog
that lived in a Mediterranean in Europe
and he became a huge predator the size
of a fox in the absence of other
predators there but that again is
another story
in jungles new creatures emerge primates
taking the shape of tarsiers at first
this is a small nocturnal primate with
eyes as big as its brain or maybe I
should say brains as small as its eyes
it needs big eyes because it's nocturnal
and that's how it finds prey primarily
insect and you wouldn't even think of
this as a primate unless you start
looking closely at its hands tarsiers at
first lemurs not much later and it's in
lemurs that leme learning became
reinforced mother started taking babies
around on their backs and longer periods
of socializing monkeys turn into Apes
even forests dry out once more another
climate change this is like the last
separation between two pieces of
Gondwana then Australia broke away from
Antarctica and South America drifted off
on its own new currents new weather
patterns and Africa became much drier
and more savannas fewer forests and that
has been probably just a handful of
bands of apes ventured out into the open
we don't know exactly where it occurred
but maybe we'll figure that out in the
next decades and that has been going
upright became a lifestyle
these are bonobos and so you can ask
yourself the question who are we in this
big story are we brothers of masculine
chimps are we sisters of feminine
bonobos well I would say that we are all
of them and more because of course every
living thing on the face of this planet
carries within itself
the history of what came before that is
the continuity of life on earth and the
one thing that connects us all is of
course DNA and it's just amazing what
we're learning just in the last 10 years
from studying DNA and seeing the
connections we are all of them and more
and we're all molded by the same force
and the blood veins in our hands is a
cross-section through a human hand
photographed in a medical collection
those blood veins echo the course water
traces on the earth and our brains our
celebrated brains reflect the drainage
of a tidal marsh but it is those brains
that make us just a little different not
as much as we like to think but just
enough that they enable us to imagine us
to imagine a whole earth
the entire animal world today lives on
oxygen produced by algae bacteria and
plants and their waste is our breath in
our exhalation is their breath we are
connected like water on land is with
clouds in the sky this earth as I now
look at it is alive as a whole and it's
made its own membrane just like cells
did once upon a time and that membrane
is an atmosphere that became a biosphere
through the interactions between land
sea and air energized by all living
things forming a whole that makes this
earth different held together and
sustained by the collective power of
life thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you